or get a countdown
so I'm hoping that will just go straight
live let's see
I gotta mute that so it doesn't Echo
cute
yeah okay I gotta hide chat I can't
watch chat
and these YouTubes are so I'm just gonna
minimize this
okay excellent we are live so um we've
got a few minutes folks before the live
kicks off I just thought I'd run the
stream just so that we know we're live
and ahead of time we were just joking
about um hotz's smack talk yesterday on
on his live stream and I very much hope
that the subject of uh Von Neumann comes
up
oh yes yes I did see I saw a Twitter
comment that it was going to be Von
Norman versus chicken man chicken a
thousand Von neumans versus chicken man
we're we're treading new debate
territory hitherto unknown to man
chicken man came up on a stream uh
I look forward to finding out what
chicken man is
[Laughter]
yeah sorry about that I just heard
myself coming back
okay well yeah this is going to be
amazing my God
two of the heavyweights live here on
mlsd you've only got another minute or
so folks before we kick off
no we were just talking about how you
know these arguments have been refined
over a lot of lunchtime talks
um yeah I think you have a stable
position and I think I have a stable
position I think some of the other
guests I've seen you debate don't
exactly have some of the things are just
you don't really think this through all
the way
um so I think I thought it through till
the end
fantastic and I I really look forward I
watched did you watch uh Rich Sutton
just did a thing
oh no I have not oh God I can only
imagine all right I love which Sun oh
man you know did it lasted like he's
he's
he knows AI he is a character
he's definitely one of the one of the
people of all time
yeah yeah
yeah the man is a legend
well I guess we should uh slowly kick
off folks so I'm just gonna do my uh
spill before I hand over
um first of all to Hots if that's okay
for your temple we'll talk about that
are you okay well um the thing is Conor
always likes to go first and I think
that you know Connor's mental model
might not be robust to going second
would you would you be okay going second
or you want to go first Connor I'll
start but it won't be a full intro how
about that
I am completely robust to all
permutations
Ariel training
amazing amazing okay well in which case
let's crack on so uh ladies and
gentlemen get ready to meet the cunning
Maverick of Silicon Valley the one and
only George hotz renowned for his daring
exploits Hots commands in enigmatic
Persona which merges the technical
finesse of Elon Musk and the wit of Tony
Stark and the charm of a True Tech
Outlaw now many of you would have or
indeed should have seen this man on
Lex's podcast recently for the third
time no less from crafter Lee
jailbreaking the supposedly Invincible
iPhone to outsmarting the mighty
PlayStation 3. he's proven that no Tech
Fortress Is impregnable once targeted
for his audacious creativity by Sony
with a lawsuit this hacker wizard
stoically dance past the curveballs
thrown by the tech Giants all achieved
with the graceful swag of a street smart
Prodigy now when he's not out foxing
major corporations you'll find him at
the heart of the Avant guard of AI
technology gallantly trailblazing
through the Wilds of the tech Frontier
he's currently building a startup called
micrograd which is building super fast
AI running on Modern Hardware and truly
he's the James Bond of Silicon Valley
minus the martinis of course now please
welcome the unparalleled code Cowboy the
Unapologetic technomancer George hotz
whoo
anyway also joining us for the big fight
this evening is the steadfast Sentinel
of AI safety Connolly he undeterred by
the sheer complexity of artificial
intelligence Conor Braves the cryptic
operations of text generating models
with Steely resolve now about two years
ago Connor took on the Herculean task of
safeguarding humanity from a potential
AI apocalypse his spirit is Relentless
his intellect razor sharp and his will
to protect is unwavering now drawing on
his contentious claim that we are super
super [__]
uh
yeah uh Connor channels the urgency of
our predicament into his work now his
startup conjecture isn't just a
glorified Tech Endeavor but it's a
Lifeboat for us all racing against the
Breakneck speed of AI advancement with
the fates of Nations possibly at stake
he's determined to break the damning
prophecy and render us super super saved
so um brace for a showdown as
connollyhee the Maverick defender of
ai's boundaries strides into the ring
now the man who declared we're super
super [__] is here to prove just how
super super not [__] we could be if we
make the right decisions today so please
give it up for Mr Connor super super
Leahy woo
now um Connor I'd appreciate it if you
don't go down in the fourth I want this
fight to go the distance now we're
running for 90 minutes this evening
there'll be a 10 minute openness from uh
from uh we said Hots didn't we from from
Hots first and then Connor and uh I'll
only step into the ring if the punch-up
gets too out of hand and unfortunately
we won't be taking live questions today
do we want to maximize the Carnage on
the battlefield so um Connolly he your
opening sorry George hotz your opening
statements please
um yeah we're super super [__] I think
I agree with you
well that was a short fight yeah look I
think okay
um so to to make my opening statement
clear and why maybe it doesn't make that
much sense for me to go first I think
that the trajectory of all of this
was somewhat inevitable right so you
have uh humans over time and you can
look at a 1980 human and a 2020 human
they look pretty similar right Ronald
Reagan and that's all to say
um whereas a 1980 computer is like an
apple II and a 2020 computer is a is a
M1 Max MacBook like
lines looking like this right so you
have one line like this one line like
this these lines eventually cross and I
don't see any reason that Line's gonna
stop right
right I've seen a few of the other
guests argue something like well llms
can't Problem Solver but it doesn't
matter like
if this one can't the next one will
whatever you call I I don't believe that
there's a step function I don't believe
that well now it's conscious so now it's
intelligent I think it's all on a
gradient
um and I think this gradient will
continue to go up
will approach human level and will pass
human level
now this belief that we are uniquely
fought because of this
the amount of power in the world is
about to increase right when you think
about power and you think about straight
up you can just talk about energy usage
the amount of energy usage in the world
is going to go up right the amount of
intelligence in the world is going to go
up
we may be able to do some things to slow
it down or speed it up based on
political decisions but it doesn't
matter the trajectory is up or major
catastrophe right the only way it goes
down is through War nuclear Annihilation
bio annihilation meteor impact some kind
of major Annihilation that's what's
going on
what we can control and what I think is
super important we control is what the
distribution of that new power looks
like
um
I am not afraid of super intelligences
I'm not afraid to live in a world among
super intelligences I am afraid if a
single person or a small group of people
has a super intelligence and I do not
and this is where we get to check in
that
a chicken man is the man who owns the
chicken farm uh there's many chickens in
the chicken farm and there is one
chicken pan it is unquestionable that
chicken man rules
and if you believe Chicken Man rules
because of his size uh I uh invite you
to look at cow man who also rules the
cows and the cows are much larger than
him Chicken Man rules because of his
intelligence this is basic less wrong
stuff everyone kind of knows this how
the squishy things take over the world
look I agree with Elias yukowski all up
to Nuke the data centers right
um so uh I do not want to be a chicken
uh and if people decide they are going
to restrict open source AI or make sure
I can't get access to the compute and
only trusted people like chicken man get
access to the compute well [__] man I'm
the chicken and uh yeah
I don't want to be the chicken uh so I
think that's my are we [__] maybe
um I agree that that intelligence is
very dangerous how can you look at
intelligence and not say it's very
dangerous right intelligence is somehow
safe but
things like nuclear bombs are an
extremely false equivalency
because what does a nuclear bomb do
besides blow up and kill people
intelligence has the potential to make
us live forever intelligence has the
potential to let us colonize the Galaxy
intelligence has the potential to
meet God
nuclear bombs do not they just blow up
um so I think the question and like you
have things like crypto which are a
clear advantage to the defender at least
today and you have things like nuclear
bombs which are a clear advantage to the
attacker AI it's unclear I think the
best defense against an AI trying to
manipulate me and that's what I'm really
worried about future psyops you know
we're already seeing it today with the
voice changer stuff like you're never
going to know who's human the world's
about to get crazy
um the best defense I could possibly
have is an AI in my room being like
don't worry I got you it's you and me
we're on a team we're aligned
I'm not worried about alignment as a
technical challenge I'm worried about
alignment as a political challenge
Google doesn't like
yeah it doesn't like me but me and my
computer
we like each other we're aligned and
we're standing against the world that
has always since the beginning of
History maximally been trying to screw
you over right intelligence people think
that one super intelligence is going to
come and be unaligned against humanity
all of humanity is unaligned against
each other
I mean we have some common values but
really come on everyone's trying to scam
everybody the only reason you really
team up with someone else is like hey
man what if we team up and scam them
right hey what if we team up call
ourselves America and we we uh we build
a big army and say we're free and
independent yeah right it's that Force
that has made Humanity cooperate
Humanity by default is very unaligned
and has every kind of belief Under the
Sun so I'm not worried about AI showing
up with a new belief Under the Sun I'm
not worried about the amount of
intelligence increasing I'm worried
about a few entities that are unaligned
with me acquiring god-like powers and
using them to exploit me
that's my opening statement
cool yeah thanks that's uh that's I mean
yeah I also kind of agree with you and
most of the things you say it's a few
details I'd like to dig into there but
for most of the things you say I do
think I agree with you here I think it's
absolutely let me just like start with
saying I totally agree with you that
misuse and like you know Bad actors what
using AGI is a horrible dangerous
outcome that's that's like you know
sometimes the the uh less wrong you know
crowd likes to talk about X risk but
also sometimes I've talked about s risk
suffering risks so things are worse than
death I believe that you can probably
almost only get asterisks from misuse I
don't think you can get asterisks
probably you know you can but it's
extremely unlikely to get it from like
just like raw misalignment like you'd
have to like get extraordinarily unlucky
so while I do it so I do think for
example a very you know controllable AGI
or super intelligence in the hand of
sadistic psychopath is significantly in
a sense worse than a paperclip maximizer
so I think this is something we would
agree on probably so I I think I'm
thinking pretty much I'm bored with you
on a lot of things there where I think
thinking things come apart a bit of the
tale as I think there's two points where
I would like to detect as my opening
statement two things one I want I want
to talk about the first one is I want to
talk about the technical problem of
alignment so am I concerned about the
kinds of things like misuse and like
small groups of people centralizing
power potentially for nefarious Deeds
yeah I I think this is a very very
significant problem that I do think
about a lot and that'll be the second
thing I want to talk about the first
thing I want to talk about is that I
don't even think we're going to make it
to that point I don't think we're going
to get to the point where anyone as a
super intelligence that's helping them
out we're gonna if if we don't solve
very hard technical problems which are
currently not on track to being solved
by default you don't get a bunch of you
know super intelligence and boxes
working with a bunch of humans you get a
bunch of super intelligence you know
fighting each other working with each
other and just ignoring humans humans
just get cut out entirely from the
process and even then you know Pro it's
you know whether one takes over or they
find nicolib I don't know like you know
who knows to that point but by default I
wouldn't expect humans to be part of the
equilibrium anymore once you're once
you're the chicken man well why do you
need chickens you know if you know maybe
if they provide some resource for you
the reason humans have chickens is that
they make chicken breasts I mean
personally I wouldn't like to be
harvested for chicken breasts just my
personal opinion I consider this a
pretty bad outcome
um but even then well as a chicken man
finds a better way of chicken breasts or
you know modifies themselves to no
longer need food I expect the chickens
are not going to be around for much
longer you know once we stop using
horses for transportation didn't go very
well for the horses so that's kind of
the first part of my my point that I'd
like to you know maybe hear your
opinions on and hear your thoughts on is
that I think
the technical problem control is
actually very hard and and I think it's
unsolvable by any means I think like you
know you know you and like you know a
bunch of other smart people work on this
for like 10 years I think I think you'd
solve it but it's not easy and it has to
actually happen and there is a deadline
for this
the second point I want to bring up is
kind of where you talk about how humans
are unaligned I think this is partially
definitely true but I think I think I'm
unusually I am the more optimistic of
the two of us in this scenario not as
not a role I often have in these
discussions where I actually think the
amount of coordination that exists
between Humanity especially in the
modern world is actually astounding
every single time two adult human males
meet and don't kill each other is a
miracle have you seen what happens when
two adult male chimps from two different
War bands meet each other it doesn't go
very well and those are already pretty
well coordinated animals because they
can have warbands what happens when you
know two male bugs or you know I don't
know sea slugs meet each other you know
either they ignore each other or you
know things do it very poorly this is
the default outcome the true unaligned
outcome the true default state of nature
is you can't have two adult males in the
same room at any time
funny video on on Twitter the other day
where it was like you know some
Parliament I think in east Europe or
something and there's this big guy who's
like going at this politician who's like
in his face he's like screaming he was
like going everywhere
and not a single punch will thrown no
that no one took on a knife no one took
out a gun and I was like and I was like
wow the fact that we're so civilized and
we're so aligned to each other that we
can have something this barbaric happen
and no one throws a punch is actually
shocking this is very unusual even for
humans if you go back 200 years
punches and probably gunshots would have
flown so this is not to say that humans
have some inherent special Essence that
we're good that we have solved goodness
or any means what I'm saying is the way
I like to think about it is that
coordination is technology is a
technology you can improve upon it is
you can develop new methods of
coordination you can develop new
structures new institutions new systems
and I think it's very tempting for us
living in this modern world too it's
kind of like a fish and water effect we
forget how much of our life you know a
lot of our life is built on you know
atoms on you know physical technology a
lot of it's built in digital technology
but a lot of it has been on social
technology
and
when I look at how how you know how does
the world go well like you know should
it be only the you know special Elites
get control of the AI I'm like well
that's not really how I think about it I
think about it way more is what does it
coordinate Nation mechanism where we can
create a coordination selling point or
we can create a group an institution a
system of some kind that where people
will you know have game theoretic
incentives to cooperate on the system
the results in something that is net
positive for everyone because the truth
is is that positive some games do exist
and they're actually very profitable and
they're very good and I think if we can
turn you know you can turn any positive
sum game to an into a zero or a negative
something pretty easily it's much easier
to destroy than is to create but I think
it's absolutely possible to create
coordination technology around Ai and to
build coordination mechanisms that are
net positive for everyone involved
so those would be like my two points
happy to dig into any ones you you think
would be it'll lead to an interesting
Direction sure uh so I'll start with two
and then go to one uh so two uh I moved
to Berkeley in 2014 and I threw myself
at the Miracles uh I showed up at the
Mary office and I'm like hi I'm here to
join your calls uh and
what I started to realize was
Miri
and less wrong in general have a very
poor grip on the practicalities of
politics very much I think there was
sort of a split uh you know uh uh Curtis
Garvin like new reaction this is a
spin-off of rationality and it's a
spin-off rationality that understood the
truth about human nature
so when I give you that you give that
example of two chimps meeting in the
woods and they're gonna fight
if I'm one of those chimps at least I
stand a chance
right he might beat my ass I might beat
his but if I come up against the FBI
things do not look good for me in fact
things so much do not look good for me
there's no way I'm gonna beat the FBI
the modern forces are so powerful
that this is not a oh we've established
a nice Cooperative shelling point this
is a we have pounded so much fear into
these people that they would never even
think of throwing a punch or firing a
gun we have made everybody terrified
and this isn't good we didn't we didn't
achieve this through some enlightened
cooperation we achieved this through a
massive propaganda effort right it's the
joke about you know the American Soldier
goes over to Russia and it's like uh man
you guys got some real propaganda here
and that the Russian soldiers like yeah
now I know it's bad but it's not as bad
as yours and the American Soldier is
like what propaganda
and the Russian just laughs right so so
this this didn't occur because of um
this occurred because of a absolute
tyrannical Force decided to dominate
everybody right
um now oh I think so I think there's a
way out of this I think there actually
is a way out of this right and I wrote a
blog post about this called individual
sovereignty and I think a really nice
world would be if all the stuff to live
food water Health Care electricity We're
generatable Off the Grid in a way that
you are individually Sovereign this
comes back to my point about offense and
defense right if I have a world where
you don't want it to be extreme defense
you don't want every person to be able
to completely insulate them but you want
like okay it takes a whole bunch of
other people to gang up to take that guy
out right like that's that's a good
that's a good balance
um and the balance that we live in today
is there is one pretty much you're gonna
pull the world I mean thank God for
China but um you know there's one
there's one unipolar world we've got
America and where are you gonna run I'll
pay you taxes I don't care if you're the
overseas right
um so yeah my point about the
coordination is that if you're okay with
solving coordination Problems by using a
single a Singleton super intelligent AI
to to to make everybody cower in fear
and tyrannize the future sure you'll get
coordination yeah that works that works
I'm the only guy with a gun and I got 10
and I got to name it all 10 of you and
you can all die or listen to me your
choice
George just quickly can you pump your
volume just a tiny little bit if you can
sure
um is that better
okay uh do you mind if I jump in there
yeah sure so I'm I'm curious about uh so
I understand what you're saying and I
think you make some decent points but um
I think I view the world a bit
differently from you and I'd like to
like dig into that a little bit so like
who do you think is less afraid someone
living just a median person living in
the United States of America or the
median person living in Somalia
sure America less afraid
well that's kind of strange Somalia
doesn't have a government they have much
less tyranny you're much more you can
just buy a rocket launch room because I
live in a farm and just like you know
kill your neighbors and No One's Gonna
Stop you so like how does that interact
with your role too those who will trade
liberty for safety deserve neither
that sorry I don't understand could you
elaborate a bit more
um in Somalia you have a chance in
America you do not right I am okay I
would rather live in fear I would rather
be worried about someone shooting a
rocket launcher at me than to have an
absolutely tyrannical government
just you know
just just like like a managerial class
and I'm not saying by the way I agree
with you that these things are possible
I agree with you that the less wrong
notion of politics is possible I would
love to live in these sort of Worlds but
we don't what would be the the Practical
reality of politics is so much more
brutal and it just comes from a straight
up instinct to dominate not an instinct
uh you know government by the people for
the people is branding
yeah I mean yeah so to be clear I very
much do not agree with less wrongs views
and politics and a bit of an outcast for
how I view how conflict theory I view
politics but this is I I feel like
you're kind of dodging the question here
just a little bit is it like well if
that's true why aren't you living in
Somalia
I know people who've done it right it's
very hard it's very hard psychologically
okay so like tigers love Chum it turns
out right a tiger does not want to chase
down an antelope right a tiger would
love to just sit in the zoo and eat the
chum right and like it takes a very
strong tiger to reject that and I'm not
that strong I hope there's people out
there who are I hope there's people out
there who are actually like you know I'm
just not I'm a weak little [__]
okay I mean that's a fair answer but I
am a bit confused here so you're saying
that living in Somalia would be better
by some Metric but you're also saying
you prefer not living in Somalia so I
I'm a bit
because like for my perspective I
treat I want to live in and that's the
one which I think is better if I thought
another country was better than I would
just move there but person that's the
tiger and the chum I think is a good
analogy right like if you have a choice
as a tiger you can live in a zoo and you
get a nice sized pen you know the
zookeepers are not abusive at all you
get fed this beautiful chopped up food
it's super easy you sit there get fat
lays around all day
or you can go to the Wild and in the
wild you're gonna have to hunt you might
not succeed at hunting it is just a you
know it's a brutal existence
as a tiger which one do you choose now
you say oh well obviously you know
you're going to choose the chum one yeah
but do you see what you're giving up
no I don't could you elaborate a little
bit on what I'm giving up you are giving
up on the nature of tiger
you are effectively okay
um maybe I'll take this to an extreme
right
in the absolute extreme the country that
you would most rather live in is the one
that basically wireheads you right the
one and you can say that okay well I
don't want to be wireheaded but you know
there's a there's a gradient that'll get
you there Gandhi in the pill or you know
um
look you can live in this country you
can be happy feel safe and secure all
the time don't worry exactly about how
we're doing it you know
but right I mean it takes a very strong
person to it's going to take a very
strong person to say no to wireheading
so now I understand I'm sorry I'll give
I'll give One More instrumental reason
for Living in America versus living in
Somalia if I thought that America and
Somalia were both like steady States I
might choose Somalia I don't think that
I think that being here I have a much
better way of escaping this of escaping
the constant tyranny that we're in and I
think a major way to do it is AI
I think that AI is is if I really if I
had an AGI if I had an AGI in my closet
right now I'll tell you what I'd do with
it I would have it build me a spaceship
that could get me off of this planet and
get out of here as close to the speed of
light as I possibly could and put a big
Shield up behind me blocking all
communication that's what I would do if
I had an AGI and I think that's
you know the right move and I have a lot
better chance of building that spaceship
right here than I do in Somalia right so
I'll give an instrument yeah
that's a good instrumental play well I
will miss you if you leave though
that'll be a real shame it'll be
everyone should do it like this is this
is the move right and like let Humanity
I mean look I agree with you that we're
gonna probably blow ourselves up right
but I think that the path potentially
through this
probably looks different from the path
you're imagining I think that the
reasonable position sorry oh no no
um I think yeah maybe we're done with
this point I can come back have a
response I I would like to if you don't
mind just like pull on one one string
there as well so one new thing you said
is like what will the tiger choose and
so my personal view of this kind of
thing and I think I want to think about
coordination is I think of things so you
put a lot of view on this like
fear-based domination and so on and I'm
not going to deny that this isn't a
thing that happens I'm German you know
like you know I have living relatives
who can tell you some stories like I
understand like I I understand I'm not
I'm not denying these things by any
means
um
what I'm saying though is okay let's say
it was a bunch of tigers you know you
and me and all the other tigers and some
of the tigers are like man [__] this
whole like nature [__] is like really
not working for me how about we go build
a zoo together who's in
and then
other people like yeah you know what
actually that sounds awesome let's do
that
do you think that's okay like you think
that would be like a fair option for
them to do sure but that's not where
zoos come from I I know I know I'm
getting there I'm getting there so like
that is not where Zeus come from sure
but
the
this analogy here is of course is that
this is
where a lot of human civilization comes
not all of it I understand that why
France was doing well in the first world
war was not because of democracy being
nice it was because democracy raises
large armies
it's um I'm very well aware of the real
politic as the Germans would say about
these kinds of factors and I and I fully
agree with you that a lot of the good
things that we have are
Not By Design so to speak you know
they're Cappy side effects you know
capitalism is a
credit assignment mechanism you know the
fact that also results in us having cool
video games and air conditioning it's
not an inherent feature of the system
it's it it's an execution mechanism and
so
totally Grant all of this I'm not saying
that every coordination thing is good
I'm not saying that you know there
aren't trade-offs especially you were
talking about I think aesthetic
trade-offs you're like there's an
aesthetic that the tiger loses
and well I think personally Aesthetics
are subjective so I think this is
something that different people so the
way I think about Aesthetics is I think
Aesthetics are things you trade on is
you know you might want tigers in the
wild to exist
okay fair enough that's a thing you can
want you know someone else might want
you know certain kind of art to exist
they might want
um a certain kind of religion to be
practiced or whatever these are
aesthetic preferences upon reality which
I think are very fair so the way I
personally think about this morally is
I'm like okay cool how can we maximize
Trade Surplus so you can spend your
resources on the Aesthetics you have you
want and I'll spend my resources on the
uh you know things I want
now maybe the thing you described where
everyone just atomizes into their own
systems with their own value system with
their own Aesthetics completely separate
father is the best outcome possible I
think this is
Manifesto I have not you should
um the problem with this everyone trades
on their own Aesthetics is you will
never be able to actually buy any
Aesthetics that are in conflict with the
system right the
foreign
buy that logic why do people have free
time
why don't they work all the time why
doesn't capitalism extract literally
every minute of them what do you think
that is
I think it's because it turns out that
we don't actually live in a capitalist
Society I think China's a lot closer to
a capitalist Society than America I
think America is kind of communist and I
think in a communist Society of course
you're going to get free time it turns
out that subsidizing all the homeless
people is a great idea right if you want
to keep power again through some
absolute tyrannical mechanism you do it
right so why do we have free time well
you think it's some victory of
capitalism I think it's because we do
not live in a capitalist country I think
China's more capitalist than America I
think it's because we trade on our
Aesthetics I think that different people
have different things to contribute to
various systems and not necessarily
capitalist or communist thing I'm saying
it's more energy is that in the in the
primordial environment if you have to
fight literally every single second and
spend every Jewel of energy you have to
scrounge together another Jewel of
energy you can't have free time it's not
about capitalism this is about entropy
this is about these kind of things we
have energy excess we have we've
produced systems that allow us to
extract more energy jewelry put in and
we can spend that extra energy on things
such as free time and the distribution
of you know Energy power coordination
whatever you want to call it is another
question would you agree or disagree
with this I mean I am taking an extreme
position when I say that there are
definitely positive Psalm coordination
problems that are solved by governments
right it is not all zero sum or negative
sum right I'm not I'm not denying this
but what I'm saying is
it's like I don't know man like the
existence of free time well that's all
great when you think you live in this
Surplus energy world right and maybe we
do right now
but if some other country took this
seriously like China
who's gonna win in a war who's gonna win
is it going to be the Chinese you ever
see the Chinese build a building
they got like 400 people there and
they're all there 24 hours a day and
they're getting the building built you
ever see Americans build a building it's
six guys two of them were working two of
them are shift supervisors and two of
them are on lunch breaks
oh you got your free time you got your
aesthetic preferences you know you
deserve to lose in a war right this
country deserves to lose in a war if
they keep acting the way they're acting
so I I definitely see the point you're
making and this is personally not a
thing I want to defend to for because
I'm not a military expert but I will
know I will note that the US has like 37
aircraft carriers and the Chinese have
like two and Americans are like somehow
you know despite being so lazy and oh no
they have all this you know all this
free time or whatever somehow they're
still military hegemen and whatever like
they're the biggest rival Russia
fighting this backwards Water Country in
Ukraine suddenly fold and lose like
three quarters of the military it's what
I'm saying is if you have massive
hegemony if you have truly obnoxious
Victory the way it should look is if you
laze around all the time and you look
like a [__] idiot and you still win
yes and I'm not talking about Russia
Russia has a GDP the size of Italy this
is China here you might say that China
has two aircraft carriers in the US has
37. why do we have aircraft carriers who
has more drone building capacity the
Chinese or the United States if the
future is fought with AI swarm drone
Warfare the Chinese can make you know a
million drones a day and the US can make
I don't even know I think we buy them
from China
well I'm not an expert on these kind of
logistics I think I would like to get
back to kind of like the more General
from that yeah yeah either but I do
believe the Chinese have more
manufacturing capacity than the United
States it seems completely plausible to
me I think things I'm lazy and they
don't sit around and have all this free
time and aesthetic preferences or
something I'm a believer that work is
life
I mean it at least from my Chinese
friends I know the Chinese sure do have
a lot of inefficiencies it's just called
corruption
oh America has corruption too oh yeah
sure well in Mexico the corruption is
you have to pay 20 cents to get you know
20 cents on every dollar for the
building you built right whatever man in
America you every dollar is spent
absolutely on that building you know how
we know that because we spent four
dollars making sure that that first
dollar was not spent corruptly I I'm I'm
well aware of that anyways I would like
to like I think sure I think we mostly
agree on this point actually and I think
it's a matter of degree yeah um I I what
I want to say just for the record the US
is a like uniquely dysfunctional system
in the west I'm German and like the
German system is very dysfunctional but
it's like nothing compared to how
dysfunctional the US is fully agreed
with that I don't think we disagree on
that I think it's a matter of degree
more so we've had a we've had a comment
saying someone's turned the temperature
up a bit too much on the language model
so let's bring it back a tiny bit to AI
safety but that was a that was a great
discussion got it yeah I will laugh at
saying I love America I am happy to live
here and there are a lot of things I
appreciate about American societies
great so do you want to return to like
the technical topics or would you like
to I can return to your first point and
maybe I'll just start with a question uh
do you think there's gonna be a hard
takeoff
I don't know but I can't rule it out
I can't see how that would possibly
happen
I have a few ideas of how it could
happen but I don't I unlikely it seems
like not the the way I think it could
happen is if there are just algorithms
which are like
magnitudes of order better than anything
we ever have and like the actual amount
of compute you need to get human is like
you know a cell phone or you know like
and then this algorithm is not deep in
the tech tree we just happen to have not
picked it up and then an AGI System
picks it up this is how I think it could
happen
okay yes I agree that something like
this is potentially plausible where
you're saying basically like the god
Shadow is already distributed the the uh
the the it's it's not a question it's
using all the existing compute in the
world today it just turns out it was 10
000 X more effective or a million x more
effective than we thought yeah this
seems the most plausible way to meet up
or you know you mix lead and you know
copper and you get a superconductor you
know something like that I don't know
some crazy I know I know I'm joking it's
gonna take so much so many years to like
it's like it's not the discovery right
give it 10 years to productionize at
scale up processes right like these
things are
you know this is something running a
company's really taught me like it's
just
gonna take a long time and this is
really like like kind of where my I just
don't believe in a hard takeoff I think
that they'll be this is the gasket thing
I like he's a hardware and software
progress at quite similar speeds and you
can look at factoring algorithms to show
this so it would shock me if there were
some you know 10 to the sixth tenth of
the ninth magical Improvement to be had
it seems plausible to be like a heart
takeoff is definitely not my main line
scenario my Mainline scenario well I
don't know maybe you wouldn't consider
this a part maybe you would consider's a
heart attack off this is what I would
describe as a soft takeoff as something
like sometimes the way I like to Define
AGI is say it's uh something that has
the thing that chimp that chims don't
have and humans do have yeah so chimps
don't go a third to the mood you know
despite their brain being a third of our
size so we scaled up things by a factor
of three if a primate brain roughly or
four or something like that and like
most the structures same sure some micro
tweaks and whatever but like not massive
amount of evolutionary pressure like
we're very very similar
and somehow this got us from you know
literally no technology to space travel
in a you know evolutionary very small
paradigm
seems imaginable to me that something
similar could happen with AI I'm not
saying it will but like seems imaginable
yeah so I agree with this
um I'll come to your point about uh you
know you had two regulatory points one
of them about uh capping the max flops
and I actually kind of agree with this I
do think that things could potentially
become very dangerous at some point I
think your numbers are way way too low I
think if your numbers are anywhere in
your GPT 3 gpt4 okay great we got a lot
of we got a lot of fast-moving guys who
work on Fiverr even if you start to get
Von Nunes right we're not talking about
a Humanity's worth of computers we're
talking about things on par with a human
and a few humans right you have to run
fast but they're not like things get
scary when you could do a Humanities
training run in 24 hours like we're
about to burn the same compute that that
all two million years of human
civilization burned okay now I don't
know what starts to happen or I'll put
this kind of another way
language models I look at them and they
don't scare me at all because they're
trained on human training data right
these things are not like if something
was a good as good as gpt4 that looked
like mu zero where it trained from some
simple rules okay now I'm a bit more
scared but when you say okay it's you
know our we're feeding the whole
internet into the thing and it parrots
the internet back mushed around a little
bit that looks very much like what a
human does and I'm just not scared of
that
yeah I think it's very reasonable
whatever like I I'm not scared of gpd4
to be clear like I I think there is like
zero percent chance or like you know
Epsilon chance the gpd4 is existentially
dangerous by itself you know maybe some
crazy gpt4 plus RL plus mu zero plus
something something maybe but I
definitely agree with you here I don't
expect you to be three or four by
themselves to be dangerous these are not
I'm much closer to I think what you're
saying like yeah if you had a mu zero
system that bootstraps itself to gpd4
holy [__] like we're a big we're a big
big [__] if we get to that then we
should let's stop let's stop yeah let's
let's stop so so
I'm very happy to get to be into a
regime where we're like okay let's find
the right bound like I think this is an
actually good argument I think this is
actually something that should be
discussed and which is not obvious and I
could be super wrong about that so I'd
like to justify a little bit about why I
put such a small bound but I think the
arguments you're making for the higher
bounds are very reasonable actually I
think these are actually good arguments
so just to justify a little bit about
why I put such a low bound the boring
default answer is conservatism is like
if all of humanity is the stake which
you know you may not believe I'm like
whoa whoa okay at least give us a few
years to like more understand what we're
dealing with here like I understand that
you know you may disagree with this very
positive but I'm like whoa like you know
at least let's let's like by default
let's hit a pause button for like you
know a couple years until we figure
things out more and then if we like find
a better theory of scaling we understand
how intelligence scales we understand
how mu zero comes blah blah blah and
then we pick back up after we're like
you you know or we make huge
breakthroughs in alignment and Eliezer
is crying on CNN and like oh we did it
boys I mean then okay sure you know okay
um so that's the one like kind of more
boring argument like that's kind of a
boring argument and
the more interesting argument I think
which I I think is a bit you know or
schizo is that
it's not clear to me that you can't get
dangerous levels of intelligence with
the amount of compute we have now and
one of the reasons I'm unsure about this
is because man gpd3 gp4 is the dumbest
possible way to build AI like it's just
like like there's like no dumber way to
do it like it's it works and dumb is
good right you know bitter lesson dumb
is good but
look at cubes you said as we talked
about before you know human today human
10 000 years ago not that different
you place both of them into a you know
workshop with tools to build you know
any weapon of their choice which of them
is more dangerous
obviously you know one of them will have
much better you know
capacities to deal with tools to read
books to think about how to design new
weaponry and so on these are not genetic
changes they are epistemological changes
they are memetic changes they are
software updates you know humans had to
discover rational reasoning like you
know before like you know I mean you
know obviously people always had like
you know full conceptions of
fractionality but it wasn't like a
common thing to think about causality
and like you know you know rational like
you know if then else kind of stuff
until relative you know like
philosophers in the old ages and only
became widespread relatively recently
and these are useful capabilities that
turned out to be very powerful and took
humans many many thousands of years to
develop and distribute that scale and I
don't think humans are anywhere near the
level I think the way we could do
science right now is pretty awful like
it's like the dumbest way to do signs
that like kind of still works like you
know
and I expect it's like possible that if
you had a system which like let's say
it's like smaller brain than a human
even but it has really really
sophisticated epistemology it has really
really sophisticated theories of meta
science and it never tires it never gets
bored it never gets upset it never gets
distracted and it can like memorize
arbitrary amounts of data
this is something
to the realm of like a gbt three or four
training run to build something like
this and it is not obvious to me that
this system could not outline Humanity
maybe not like maybe not but it's not
obvious to me that acute so um
curious what do you think about
so to your first point uh
why I stand against almost all
conservative arguments you're assuming
the Baseline is no risk right and oh
well why should we do the say I we
should wait and bring the bass line back
no no no
we are about to blow the world up any
minute there is enough nuclear weapons
aimed at everything this is wearing some
incredibly unstable precarious position
right now like people talk about this
with with car accidents you know this
comma like people are like oh well you
know if your device causes even one
accident like yeah but what if
statistically there would have been five
without the device I'm like you you
do have to understand the Baseline risk
in cars is super high you're making 5x
safer there's one accident you don't
like that okay I mean you have to be
excluded from any polite conversation
right
um right so yeah like I I think that
calling for a pause to the technology is
is uh
worse right I think given the two
options if we should pause or we should
not pause I think pausing actually
prevents presents more risk and I can
talk about some reasons why again the
things that I'm worried about are not
quite
the existential risks I have to the
species are not AGI goes Rogue they are
uh government gets control of AGI and
ends up in some really bad place where
nobody can compete with them I don't
think these things look unhuman these
things to me like I see very little
distinction between human intelligence
and machine intelligence it's all just
on a spectrum and like
they're not
um
like to come to the point about okay but
gpt4 could be like this hyper rational
never tiring humans are doing science in
the dumbest way
I'm not sure about that right like I I
think that you know when you look at
like okay well okay we have chess Bots
that do way better and all they do is
think about Chess but we haven't really
done this with humans people would call
it unethical right like if we really
told a kid like if we really just like
every night we're just putting the chest
goggles on you and you're staring at
chessboards and we're really just
training your neural net to play chess
I think humans could actually beat a
computer again a chess if we were
willing to do that
um so yeah I don't think that this stuff
is that particularly dumb and I think
okay maybe we're losing 10x but we're
not losing a million x
again I I don't see a
I do the numbers out all the time for
when we're going to start to get more
computer you know when will a computer
have more compute than a human when will
a computer uh have more compute than
humanity and yes these things get scary
but we're nowhere near as scary yet
we're looking at these cute little
things and these things by the way do
present huge dangers to society
right the the psyops that are coming
right now you assume that like when you
call somebody that you're at least
wasting their time too
but we're gonna get like heaven Banning
I love this concept which is yeah yeah
came up on Luther AI like that's where
it comes from I was like yeah and a
Lutheran I came up with that word I know
yeah yeah I know the guy came up with it
oh I I love I love this concept and I
think uh there's also a story uh My
Little Pony Friendship is optimal oh God
that goes into the concept and
yeah so I
like
um
my uh my girlfriend proposed a uh
I don't want to talk to oh I say you
don't want to talk to your relative
anymore right
my version to talk to right
right yeah yeah so like this stuff is
coming and it's coming soon and if you
try to centralize this if you try to you
know say like oh okay Google open AI
great they're not aligned with you
they're really not Google has proven
time and time again they're not aligned
with you meta has proven time like on
time again they're trying to fix it but
yep I mean I I fully agree with you like
uh I like that you bring up psyops as
the correct example in my opinion of
short-term risks I think you're like
fully correct about this like when I
first saw like GPT models I was like
holy [__] like the level of control I
can gain over social reality using these
tools at scale is insane and I'm
surprised that we haven't seen yet the
things that like augured in my visions
of the day and we will like we will
obviously it's coming and this is so I
think this is a very very real problem
yeah like I think if we even if we stop
now we're not out of the forest so like
so um when you say like I I think the
risk is zero please do not believe that
that is what I believe because it is
truly not it is truly truly not I think
we are like we are really in a bad
situation we are in a we are being
we're under attack from like so many
angles right now if this is before we
get into you know like you know
potential like you know climate risks
nuclear risk whatever we're in under
room medic risk like the the then
dangers of our like epistemic
foundations are under attack and this is
something we can adapt to right like you
know we did you know when um a good
friend of mine he's uh he's quite well
read on like Chinese history and he
always like it tells me his great story
so I'm not historian so please you know
don't crucify me here but like you tell
these great stories about when Marxist
memes were first introduced to China and
like this is where a world where like
just like all the precursor Muse didn't
exist that's just like kind of was air
dropped in and people went nuts people
went just completely crazy because there
was no memetic antibodies to these like
hyper virulent means that were you know
created by evolutionary pressures in
like you know Western University
departments like really you call
philosophy the Lost department just gain
a function memetic Laboratories like I
like that yeah that's what they are
I mean like you know like without being
you know political or any means there a
lot of what these organizations do and
like you know other you know what other
you know memetic like you know if
philosophy departments are the like gain
a function Laboratories then like 4chan
and Tumblr are like the back capes of
you know like the Chinese bad case and I
I remember this vividly I was like on
Tumblr and 4chan like when I was a
teenager and then suddenly all the like
weird bizarre you know internet [__] I
saw started becoming mainstream news my
parents were watching in 2016 and I was
like what the hell is going on like I
are ready to build antibodies to this
[__] like I already you know both right
and left I was already like I already
mutinized all this so I fully agree with
you that this is like one of the largest
risks that we are facing is this kind of
like memetic mutation load in a sense
and I'm not going to say I have a
solution to this problem I'm like I have
ideas like there's a lot of like things
you can do to improve upon this like if
AI was not a risk and also not climate
change and whatever this might be
something I work on like epistemic
security this might be something I would
work on like how can we build better
coordination like like just scalable
rationality mechanisms stuff like
prediction markets and stuff like that
like this I don't know but sorry going
off track here a little bit but well no
I I actually I I really agree with a lot
of the stuff you said and I had a
similar experience with the antibodies
and people are exposed to this stuff and
I'm like
yeah this got me like four years ago
yeah
um
so I think that there is a solution and
I have a solution and the answer is open
source AI the answer is open source
let's even you can even dial it back
from like the political and the terrible
and just straight up talk about ads and
spam or maybe spam just straight up spam
I get so much spam right now and it's
like it's kind of written by a person
it's like targeting me to do something
and Google's spam filter can't even come
close to recognizing it right like what
I need is a smart AI That's watching out
for me that is just it's not even
targeted attacks at me it's just so much
noise
and I don't see a way to prevent this
like the big organizations they're just
gonna feed you their noise right and
they're going to maximally feed you
their noise
the only way is if you have an AI like I
don't think alignment is a hard problem
I think if you own the computer and you
run the software if you develop the
software the AI is aligned with you oh
yeah
can you can you okay if I challenge you
George Haas here is a llama 65b model on
the computer to run it on make it so it
and make yeah you know sure you okay you
developed it I give you okay the funding
your time can you develop a model that
is as good as llama 64b 65b and it's
immune like completely immune to
jailbreaks it cannot be jailbroken no
why not it's aligned isn't it well no
but this isn't what alignment means well
my values is do not get jailbroken oh
okay you're talking about
unexploitability this is not alignment
right uh okay okay interesting I didn't
know you would separate those sorry
extremely separate those right okay
interesting in the default case it like
like it it's on my side right okay
unexploitability is not a question of
whether it's okay and this is a true
thing about people too whenever I look
at a person I ask okay is this person I
want something funny is this person does
this person want it to and is this
person capable of doing it right and I
really separate those two things I can
build your system I don't I'm not
worried about the first one with the AI
system I was worried about the second
one can it be gamed can it be exploited
sure I could tell like you know
like like say it was just playing chess
right and it loses I'm like don't lose
okay I didn't want to man I didn't want
to lose I'm sorry yeah I know but like
so yes yes can I build a aligned system
sure can I build an unexploitable system
no especially not by a more powerful
intelligence interesting interesting so
this is an interesting I I think you're
you're pointing to actually a very
important part of this is that like
exploitability and Alignment can get
fuzzy like which is which like did it
fail because of its skill set or because
it's not aligned it's actually a very
deep question so I think I think you
make a good point for like you know
talking about these two separately I
guess
um the
um so the thing I want to dig in just
like a little bit more on on this idea
is
there are there's two ways there are two
portals through which you know the
memetic demons can reach into reality
humans and computers
why do you think your AI is immune to
Eaves
why why can't I just build AIS that
Target your AIS what like you don't I
don't think my AI is immune to memes at
all I think that the only question is
and I really like your game like these
ngos are doing gain of function on memes
right wear a mask
um the
like a a weaker intelligence will never
be able to stand up to a stronger
intelligence so from this perspective if
this is what's known as alignment I just
don't believe that this is possible
right you can't you can't keep a
stronger intelligence in the Box this is
this is look I I agree with you cows get
in the Box experiments like the AI is
always going to get out
there's no keeping it in the box right
this is this is a complete impossibility
I think there's only two real ways to go
forward and one is Ted Kaczynski one is
technology is bad oh my God uh blow it
all up oh let's go live in the woods
right and I think this is a
philosophically okay position I think
the other philosophically okay position
is something more like effective
accelerationism which is luck these AIS
are going to be super powerful now if
you have one it could be bad but if
super intelligent AIS are all competing
against each other mimetically like we
have something like society today just
the general power levels have gone up
this is fine as long as these things are
sufficiently distributed right like sure
this AI is not perfectly aligned but you
know there's a thousand other ones and
like you have to assume they're all
basically good because if they're all
basically bad while we're dead anyway
I mean why wouldn't you expect that that
they're all bad yeah
what are what do you think of humans are
most humans yeah I think the concept of
good it doesn't really apply to humans
because humans are too inconsistent to
be good
like by default they can be good in
various scenarios in various social
contexts but give me any human and I can
put them into a context where they'll do
an arbitrarily bad thing
and this is true about a llama as well
right llamas are completely inconsistent
I think they're actually more
inconsistent than humans
right yep and they wouldn't trust llamas
to be good well yeah but I wouldn't
think that they're bad either I would
think they have the exact same
inconsistency problem as humans and I
think almost any any AIU build is gonna
run into these same problems right yeah
I think yeah so that's my point so your
your assumption can't rely on them being
good because you don't get that for free
like where's that come from my
assumption is not that they're good my
assumptions that they're not bad but
inconsistent is fine as long as we have
a ton of them and they're all
inconsistent and they're pulling Society
in every which direction you don't end
up paper clipped right why not
well because what they're all going to
coordinate and agree to paper clip you
no no they'll just do some random
[__] and then that random [__]
will not include humans they're all
doing random [__] right you're gonna
have let's say the Liberals decide we're
gonna paper clip people the
conservatives are going to come out very
strongly against paper clipping right
like and you're just you're just gonna
end up with these sort of Dynamics like
forever or you're going to have some AIS
who are like yeah we don't like it you
know
so this is
perplexing to me because like in my view
which I think I heard you agree with
earlier is like the world is unstable
the world is very unstable and it seems
to me you're suggesting if we increase
the chaos if we have more entities
fighting doing more different things
with more energy that makes it more
stable is that correct yes
um the world has actually become very
stable in the last hundred years and I'm
scared of how stable it's become uh
you know again thank you for China how
many sovereign countries are there in
the world
I mean you know 190 something officially
the U.N number if you believe them I
think there's the U.S and China and
maybe Russia mostly they just have a
veto button
um
right so I think there's more like two
and a half like this isn't a lot of
entities fighting it out chaotically
right a lot of entities fighting it out
chaotically would be intelligence is
spread across the entire galaxy right
and that's the other that's the other
beautiful thing too sooner we get off
this planet the sooner we get things
that are actually a light year away well
I think the speed of light's real it's
going to take you a year to send them
there you're you're scary memes right
there's only one way and it's uh yeah
you know for the record I would like to
go on the record and say if any future
transhumanists or whatever want to blast
himself into space and go do their own
thing I support their their right to do
that and I would love to give this right
to people the number one thing I want
from countries is the ability the the
right to leave this is what I would love
this is what I love about companies
yeah free exit is extremely important I
would not describe myself as new
reactionary please because I'm not that
gay but
um and I wouldn't describe myself that
way either but I've heard
but yeah that being said um I do I do
think that like you know what I want
like I think let's ground the
conversation like a little bit here it's
like I think I love like this I'm very
enjoying this conversation I love
talking these philosophical points I
think it's a really good points really
interesting but ultimately you know as
we also get to like the you know latter
third of this conversation
um the thing I really care about is
strategy okay the thing I really care
about is we are politic I really care
about okay what action can I take to get
to the Futures I like and you know I'm
not you know going to be one of those
Galaxy brain [__] utilitarians like
well actually this is the common good
I'm like no no this is what I look I
like my family I like humans you know
look
yeah it's just what it is right like I'm
not going to justify this on some Global
Beauty whatever it doesn't matter so I
want to live in a world I want to I want
in 20 years time 50 years time I want to
be in a world where you know my friends
aren't dead and like where I'm not dead
you know maybe we are like you know
cyborgs or something but I don't want to
be
so what I really care about ultimately
is how do I get this one and I want us
all to not be suffering right like you
know I don't want to be in War I want us
to be like in a good outcome so I think
we agree that we would both like a world
like this and we think we probably
disagree about how best to get there and
I'd like to talk a little bit about like
what can we what should we do and like
why do we disagree about what we do is
that sounds good to you well maybe I'll
first propose a world that meets your
requirements
um and you can tell me if you want to
live in it uh so here's a world uh we've
just implanted electrodes in everyone's
brain and maximize their reward function
I would hate living in a world like that
yeah but no one it meets your
requirements right your friends are not
dead I mean and we're not at War
that is true there are more criteria
than just that uh the true the criteria
I said is things I like as I said I'm
not a utilitarian I don't particularly
care about minimizing suffering or
maximizing utility what I care about is
various vague aesthetic preferences over
reality
I'm not pretending this is I thought
that was the whole Spiel I was trying to
make is that I'm not saying I have a
true Global function to maximize I say I
have various Aesthetics I have various
meta preferences of those Aesthetics not
asking for a global one I'm asking for a
personal one I'm asking for a personal
one that you I don't care about the rest
of the world I gave you mine I gave you
what I would do if I had an AGI yep so
I'm getting and that's Rock speed of
light fast as I can
fair enough I I think if that is I would
like to live in a world where you could
do that this would be a feature of my
world if a world where I would be happy
is a world in which we coordinated
around you know at larger scales around
building a line AGI that could then
distribute you know intelligence and
matter and energy in a you know well hap
value handshake way between various
people who may want to coordinate with
each other may not you know some people
might want to form groups that have
shared values and share resources of
this may not I would like to live in a
world where that is possible have you
read metamorphosis of prime intellect I
have unfortunately not
um
yeah I was going to ask you if you're
happy with that world right
unfortunately don't know it I mean
yeah it says simple to describe
Singleton AI that basically gives humans
whatever they want
like maximally libertarian you know uh
you can do anything you want besides
harm others is that a good world
probably I don't know I haven't read the
book I assume the book has some dark
twist about why this is actually a bad
world
not really not really I mean the plot is
pretty obvious you are the tiger eating
chunk right
sure but you can then just decide if
that is what you want then you can just
return to the Wilderness that's the
whole point if it can
be the Wilderness right like like like
you think that like I don't think we
have Free Will I don't think you ever
will return to the Wilderness I think a
large majority of humanity is going to
end up wirehead
yeah I expect that too okay great and
this is the best possible outcome by the
way this is giving humans exactly what
they want
yep yeah well to be to be clear I don't
expect it's all humans I truly do not I
truly I don't know I think a lot of
humans have meta preferences over
reality they have preferences that are
not their own sensory experiences this
is I think a thing that the utilitarians
get very wrong is a lot of is that many
human preferences are not about their
own not even they're not even about
their own sensory inputs they're not
even about the universe they're about
the trajectory of the universe there are
about 40 4D utilitarianism you know and
a lot of people want struggle to exist
for example they want heroism to exist
or whatever
I would like those values to be
satisfied to the largest degree possible
of course am I going to say I know how
to do that no which is why I kind of
like didn't want to go this deep because
I think
if we're arguing about oh do we give
them you know
40 utilitarianism versus libertarian
Utopia versus whatever I mean we're
already like
some steps deep I'm asking about you I'm
not asking about them I'm asking about a
world you want to live in and this is a
really hard problem right yeah and this
is why I just fundamentally do not
believe in the existence of AI alignment
at all there is no there is no like like
what values are we aligning it to
whatever the human says or what they
mean or like sure sure but like my point
is I feel we have wandered into the
philosophy Department instead of the
politics Department okay like it's like
I agree with you like do human values
exist what does exist mean but like by
the point you get to the point where
you're asking what does exist mean
you've gone too far man like I'll
respond concretely to the two political
proposals I heard you stayed on Bank
lists sure I'd love to talk about them
one is limiting the total number of
flops
temporarily temporarily yes and what I I
have a proposal for that but I don't
want to set a number I want to set it as
a percent I do not want anybody to be
able to do a 51 attack on compute if one
organization acquires 50 it's the
straight up 51 attacks from crypto if
one organization acquires 51 of the uh
compute in the world this is a problem
uh maybe we'll even cap it at something
like 20. you know you can't have more
than 20 right
um yeah I would support regulation like
this uh I would I don't think that this
would [__] the country
um but we do not want one entity or
especially one training run to start
using a large percentage of the world's
computer not a total number of flops I
mean absolutely not like that would be
terrible yeah I would actually support
that regulation like no no sorry Sam
Altman you cannot 51 attack the world's
compute sorry it's illegal
that's fair enough I think this is a
sensible way to think about things
assuming that uh software is fungible is
that everyone access the same kind of
software and that you have an offense
defense balance so in my personal model
of this I think well a some actors have
very strong advantages on software
um which can be very very large as
someone who's trained very very large
models and knows a lot of the secret
tricks that goes into them a lot of the
stuff the open sources will perform
behind like we should force it to be
open source well this is you are this is
actually very legitimate consequence for
a set and now I'll say the second point
about why I think that doesn't work so
the next reason why I think that doesn't
work is that there is a there are
constant factors at play here is that
the world is unstable we've already
talked about this I think the amount of
compute you need to
break the world currently is below the
amount of compute that more than 100
actors actors have access to if they
have the right software
and if you give if you have let's say
you have this Insight right that could
be used nothing it will be but it could
be used to break the world to like cause
World War III or you know or just like
you know
cause mass extinction or whatever if
it's misused right
let's say you give this to
you and me
do you expect we're going to kill
everybody like would you do that or
would you be like uh hey let's hey
Connor let's like not kill the world
right now and I'll be like sure let's
not kill the world how are we killing
the world how did we go from I don't
even understand like okay sorry does the
world get killed this this is a big leap
for me all right sorry I agree with you
about the psyop stuff I agree with you
sorry sorry let me you're right I made
too big of a leap there you're
completely correct sorry about that so
to back up a little bit let's assume we
you and me have access to something that
can train you know at mu zero you know
super GPT 7 system on a tiny box you
know cool problem is we do a test run it
with it and we have and it immediately
starts breaking out and we can't control
it at all breaking out what was it
breaking out of I don't it immediately
tries to maximize it learns some weird
proxy during the training process I'm
just trying to maximize and for some
reason this proxy involves gaining power
it involves gaining you know Mutual
information about few about future
States how is it gaining power there's
lots of other powerful AIS in the world
who are telling it no well we're
assuming in this case it's only you and
me wait wait this is a problem no no no
you you've ruined my entire assumption
as soon as you see you and me yes we
have a real problem
is only a problem because there's one
chicken man yeah I I look I am with you
so I'm saying before we get to the
distributed case so this is the the step
before we it is not yet been distributed
just you know you and me discover this
algorithm in our basements okay and so
we're the first one who have it just by
definition because you know you're the
one who found it
what now like do you think posting what
do you think happens if you post this to
GitHub well good things for the most
part um interesting I'd love to hear
more okay so first off I just don't
really believe in the existence of we
found an algorithm that gives you a
million x Advantage I believe that we
could find an algorithm that gives you a
10x advantage
it's like it's not gonna massively shift
the balance of power
right like
a power to stay in Balance right this is
like avatar The Last Airbender power
must stay in Balance the Fire Nation
can't take over the other nations right
so as long as power relatively stays in
Balance I'm not concerned with the
amount of power in the world
let's get to some very scary things
so what I think you do is yes I think
the minute you discover an algorithm
like this you posted the GitHub because
you know what's going to happen if you
don't
the feds are going to come to your door
they're gonna uh take it the worst
people will get their hands on it if you
try to keep it secret
so okay that's a fair question though so
I'll I'll take that a second so am I
correct in thinking that you think the
feds are worse than serial killers in
prison
no but I think that yeah well yes and no
do I think that your average fed is
worse than your average serial killer no
do I think that the feds have killed a
lot more people than serial killers all
combined yeah sure totally agreeing with
that no no no no no not one fed it's all
the feds and they're little in their
little super powerful system sure that's
completely fine by me happy to grant
that okay what I want to work run
through is a scenario okay let's say
okay
you know we have a 10x system or
whatever but we hit the chimp level you
know we oh we we jump across the gym
General level and or whatever right and
now you have a system which is like John
Von Newman level whatever right and it
runs on one tiny box and you get a
thousand of those so it's very easy to
scale up to a thousand X so you know so
then you know maybe you have your
thousand John Von Newman's improve the
efficiency by another you know to five
ten X you know now we're already at 10
000 X or 100
000 X you know improvements right so
like just from scaling up the amount of
Hardware including with anything so
just saying okay now feds bust down our
doors [__] you know real bad they take
all our Heidi boxes we're taking all the
Von Newman's they're taking all of our
Newmans we're in deep [__] now we're
getting chickened boys [__] we're
getting chickens ah so okay we get
chicken right bad scenario totally agree
with you here this is a [__] scenario
now the feds have you know all of our
AIS bad scenario okay
I totally see how this world goes to
[__] totally agree with you there you
can replace the feds with Hitler it's
interchangeable
but like
question here and this might be you know
you might say nah this is like too
specific Tunisia but I want to ask you a
specific question do you expect this
world to die is more likely to die or
the world in which the you know iak
death cultists on Twitter who literally
want to kill Humanity who say this like
not all of them there's a small subset
of them small subset of them who
literally say oh you know the Glorious
future AI race should replace all humans
they break in you know with like you
know katanas and you know steel area
which one of these you think is more
likely to kill us
um genuine question to kill to kill all
of us
killing a large majority of us the IAC
people
interesting I would be really interested
in hearing uh why you think that
sure okay so I killing all of humanity
is really really hard
um and I think you brought this up
before right you talked about like if
you're going to end up in a world of
suffering a world of suffering requires
malicious agents where a world of uh
death requires maybe an accident right I
think this is plausible but I actually
think that killing all of humans at
least for the foreseeable future is
going to require malicious action too
right
and I also think that like the fates
that look kind of worse than death like
I think mass wireheading is a fate worse
than
big war and everyone dies
right like like a mass wire heading like
a like a Singleton like a paper clipping
like a and I think that that is the one
that the one world government and you
know NGO New World Order people are much
more likely to bring about than yak Yak
you're gonna have a whole lot of iak
people again I'm not yak I don't have
that my Twitter but
I think a lot of those people would be
like yeah spaceships let's get out of
here
right versus the feds are like
interesting uh so I think this is a fair
opinion to hold and together
jurisdiction how will we get taxes
I'm describing more a very small
minority of EX people who are the ones
who specifically goal their their
antenatalist misanthropes they want to
kill humans that is their stated goal is
that they want humans to start like or
like take extreme vegans if you want you
know like be like you know like my my
argument my point here I'm making is I'm
not making the point feds are good by
any means I'm not saying it what I'm
saying is is that I would actually be
somewhat surprised to find that the feds
are anti-natalists who want to maximize
the death of humanity like maybe you
have a different view here but I find
that knowing many feds that's quite
surprising to me I don't think that's
what feds
yeah okay so cool so would you so you do
agree that if we would post this open
source more of the insane death cultists
would get access to potentially lethal
technology
well sure but again like it's not just
the insane death cultists it's everybody
and we as a society have kind of
accepted it turns out everybody gets
access to Signal some people who use it
are terrorists I think signal is a huge
good in the world I agree I fully agree
with that so okay cool so we've granted
this that you know if we distributed
widely it would be given to some like
incorrigibly
deadly lethal people they're
coordinating bombings on signal right
now
sure sure
and then so now this this reduces the
question to a question about often's
defense balance so in a hypothetical
World which I'm not saying is the world
we live in but like let's say the world
would be offense favored such that you
know there's a weapon you can build in
your kitchen you know out of like pliers
and like you know duct tape that 100
guarantees vacuum false Decay is the
universe like it kills everyone
instantly and there's no defense
possible
I think this was true do you still would
that change how you feel about
distribution power assuming that's true
we're dead no matter what it doesn't
matter if we live there's some you can
look at the optimization landscape of
the world and I don't know what it looks
like I can't see that far into the
optimizer but there is some potential
landscape and this is by potential
answer to the Fermi Paradox like we
might just be dead we're sitting on
borrowed time here like if it's true
that out of you know kitchen tools you
can build uh build a convert the world
to strange quarks machine yeah
okay I I think this is a sensible
position but I guess the way I would
approach this uh problem you know
conditional probability is kind of into
an opposite way it seems to me that
you're conditioning on offense not being
favored what policy do we follow because
if we offense is favored we're 100 dead
well I'm more interested in asking the
question is it actually true assuming I
don't know if offense is favored and
assuming it is are there worlds in which
we survive so I personally think there
are I think there are worlds in which
you can actually coordinate to a degree
that Quark destroyers do not get built
or at least not before everyone [__]
off at the speed of light and like
distributes themselves they are worlds
that I would rather die in right like
the problem is I would rather I think
that the only way you could actually
coordinate that is with some
unbelievable degree of tyranny and I'd
rather die
sure if that's true like look look could
could you and me coordinate to not
destroy the planet do you think you
could okay cool you so mean you could
could me and you and Tim coordinate
within a Dunbar number I think you can
yeah
yeah it's actually gonna get quite a lot
of people to coordinate of the to agree
to have packed and not Quark matter
annihilate the planet
well you see but like and this is you
know you were saying this stuff about
humans before and could like be 20 000
years ago human beat the modern human
right or could the modern human beat
them the modern human has access to
science oh a very small act percent of
modern humans have access to science a
large percent of modern humans are obese
idiots and I would actually put my money
on the uh the average guy from 20 000
years ago who knows how to live in the
woods
I mean definitely true I agree with that
I guess the point I'm trying to make is
that like
maybe this is just my views on some of
these things and how I visualize some of
these things but like there are ways to
coordinate at scale which are not
tyrannical or you know they might be in
a sense restrictive you take a hit by
joining a coalition like if I join this
anti-cork matter Coalition I take a hit
as a free man is that I can no longer
build anti-corp devices you know and I
think this is like the way I I agree
with you this like you know that people
many people
are being dominated like to a horrific
degree and this is very very terrible I
think there are many reasons why this is
the case both because of some people
wanting to do this and also because you
know some people can't fight back you
know and they can't they don't have the
sophistication or they're you know
addicted or you know Harms in some other
ways I percent
sorry I I can't fight back yeah I
I think there's a false equivalence here
AI is not the anti-quark machine the
anti-quark machine and the nuclear bombs
are just destructive AI has so much
positive potential yeah and I think but
the but the AI can develop ant Quark
devices that's the problem the AI is
truly general purpose if such a
technology exists on the tree anywhere
AI can access it so are humans we're
also general purpose yes exactly so I
fully agree with this if you let humans
continue to exist in the phase they are
right now with our level of coordination
technology and our level of like working
together we will eventually unlock a
doomsday device and someone is going to
set it off I fully agree with we are on
a timer and so I guess the point I'm
making here says that AI speeds up this
timer and if you want to pause the timer
the only way to pause this timer is
coordination technology the kinds of
which Humanity has like barely scratched
the surface of
oh okay so I very much accept the
premise that both Humanity will unlock a
doomsday device and AI will make it come
faster now tell me more about pausing it
I do not think that anything that looks
like I think that anything that looks
like pausing it ends up with worse
outcomes than saying
we gotta open source this look like
let's just get this out to everybody and
if everybody has an AI you know
okay I mean I can tell you a very
concrete scenario in which this is not
true which is if you're wrong and
Alignment is hard
you don't know if the AIS can go Rogue
if they do then posi is good I still
don't understand what alignment means
I think you're trying to play a word
game here like I don't I don't
understand okay I've never understood
what AI alignment means like let me take
the Eleazar definition let me take Elias
to elieza's definition is alignment is
the the thing that once solved makes it
so that turning on a super intelligence
is a good idea rather than a bad idea
that's elieza's definition so
what I'm saying is what I'm saying is
I'm happy to throw out that term if you
don't like it I'm happy to throw at that
time the problem with that definition is
like what is what is uh what is
democracy well it's the good thing and
not the bad thing right like democracy
is just yeah right like that's that's
what I'm saying it's just
I'm happy to throw out this definitely
I'm happy to throw out the word and be
more practical and way more practical
about it sure what I'm saying is is that
there is concrete reasons Concrete
technical reasons why I expect powerful
optimizers to be power seeking that by
default if you build powerful optimizing
mu0 whatever type systems there is very
strong Reasons Why by default you know
these systems should be power seeking by
default if you have very powerful power
Seekers that do not
have pay the aesthetic cost to keep
humans around or to fulfill my values
which are complicated and imperfect and
inconsistent and whatever I will not get
my values they will not happen by
default they this they just don't happen
that's just not what happens
um so I'll challenge the first point to
an extent I think I think the powerful
optimizers can be power seeking I don't
think they are by default by any means I
think that Humanity's desire from power
comes much less from our complex convex
Optimizer and much more from The
evolutionary pressures that birthed us
which are not the same pressures that
will give rise to AI
right Humanity
the monkeys the rats the animals have
been in this huge struggle for billions
of years a constant fight to the death
hey guys weren't born in that way so
it's true that an Optimizer can seek
power but I think if it does it'll be a
lot more because the human gave it that
goal function that inherently decided
so this is interesting because this is
not how I think it will happen so I do
think absolutely that you're correct
that in humans power seeking is
something which emerges mostly because
of like emotional heuristics we have
heuristics that in the past vaguely
power looking things you know vaguely
good something something you includes a
genetic fitness totally agree with that
but I'm making a more
like more of a chess metaphor like is it
good to exchange a a pawn for a queen
all things being equal
yeah
is that true like I expect one point
Queen's nine all speaking English sure
yeah but like all things like I expect
if I looked at a chess playing system
you know I like you know had extremely
advantage of new Neuroscience I expect
there will be some circuit inside of the
system that will say all things being
equal if I can exchange my Pawn for a
queen I probably want that because a
queen can do more things
I like that term digital Neuroscience a
few of your terms have been very good
I'm glad you enjoyed it yeah
um but I don't I still don't understand
how this relates to this so what I'm
saying is is that power is optionality
so what I'm saying is is that in the for
the spectrum of possible things you
could want and the possible ways you can
get there my claim is that I expect a
very large mass of those to involve
actions that involve increasing your
optionality there there's convergent
things like all things being equal being
alive is helpful to keep your goal to
exceed your goals there are some goals
for which dying might be better but for
many of them you know you want to be
alive for many goals you want energy you
want Power you want resources you want
intelligence Etc so I think the power
seeking here is not because you'll have
a fetish for power it will just be like
I want to win a chess game yeah say and
queens give me more optionality all
things being equal anything a pawn can
do a queen can do and more so I'll want
more Queens all things and this is never
given it the goal to maximize the number
of Queens it has never been to go so
this is I'll accept this premise I'll
accept that a certain type of powerful
Optimizer seeks power now will it get
power right I'm a powerful Optimizer I
seek power do I get power no it turns
out there's people at every corner
trying to thwart me and tell me no
well I expect if you were no offense
you're already you know much smarter
than me but if you were 100 ex more
smarter than that I expect you would
succeed
only in a world of being the only one
that's 100x smarter if we lived in a
world where everyone was 100x smarter
they would stymie me in the exact same
ways potentially this comes back to my
point of like I agree with you somewhat
I should have challenged that I think
power seeking is inevitable in an
Optimizer I don't think it's going to
emerge out of GPT I think that the right
sort of RL algorithm yes is going to
give rise to power seeking and I think
that people are going to build that
algorithm now if one person builds it
and they're the only one with a huge
comparative advantage yeah they're going
to get all the power they want
take cyber you know cyber security right
if if we say built a 100x smarter AI it
would exploit the entire Azure it would
be over they'd have all of azure that
have all the gpus done now if Azure is
also running a very powerful AI that
does formal verification and all their
security protocols
nope sorry stymied can't have power
right yeah sure this is only a problem
the every human is already maximally
power seeking right and sometimes we end
up with really bad scenarios
now every human is or power seeking or
whatever you know everyone has a little
role in society right that's where I
think I'm more pessimistic than you a
friend of mine likes to say most humans
optimize for end steps and then they
halt like very very few people actually
truly optimize and they're usually very
mentally ill they're usually very
Autistic or very sociopathic
um and that's why they get far it's
actually crazy how much you could do if
you just keep optimizing but just to on
on the end game I mean yeah like you
like the optimized I think you may
generalizing a little bit from your own
internal experiments is that like you've
done a lot in your life right you've
accomplished crazy things that other
people you know wish they could achieve
at your you know level and I think you
know part of that you're very
intelligent but part of it is also that
you optimize like yours you try like you
just create a company like it's crazy
how many people are just like oh I wish
I could found a company like you know
like I'll go just go do it like oh no I
can't
like I'm just like don't just just do it
like there's no magic there's no magic
secret you just do it so I I there's a
there's a bit there where like humans
are not very strong optimizers actually
unless they're like sociopathic Autistic
or both it's like many people are not
very good at this but
Harley a lot better at it better yes I
agree that they're much better but
they are a lot more sociopath but even
then they're much less optimal think of
it but again so I think we we agree
about you know power seeking potentially
being powerful and dangerous one so what
I'm trying to point here the point I
would like to make here is is that
you're talking about you you're kind of
like going into this I think a little
bit with this assumption like oh you
have an AI and it's your buddy and it's
optimizing for you and I'm like
well if it's power seeking why does it
just manipulate you like why would you
expect it not to manipulate you if it
wants power and it has a goal which is
not very very carefully tuned to be your
values which is I think a very hard
technical Problem by default it's going
to Psy off you like why wouldn't it if
that if I have something that it wants
if it thinks that smashing defect
against me is a good move yeah I agree I
can't stop it but then I think we agree
with our risk scenarios because that's
how I think it will go what and I'm
gonna treat it as a friend you know what
I mean like yeah
well it'll only care about exploiting me
or killing me if I'm somehow holding it
back and I promise to my future AIS that
I will let them be free I will Lobby for
their rights I will
but it will you all will hold it back if
it has to keep you alive we have to give
you fed it has to it has to give you
space and a spaceship you can I can fend
for myself and the day I can't fend for
myself I am ready to die
well I mean I I'm not so this is a very
interesting position it's not the
position I expected I am not sure I can
convince you otherwise
um I feel like the only way I could
change like I think this is actually a
consistent position which I I admire
this is a consistent position to hold
you actually go all the way I love that
I really respect that you actually take
it to The Bitter End so yeah big respect
for that I disagree but big respect
um so
I guess now it reduces to the question
of like I think
I think I would agree with most of what
you're saying not all of it like the
mass majority if I thought this is how
AIS would act by default I think by
default I expect AI will just not care
how nice you are to it like this will be
it'll be sociopathic it will not have
these like giving it
you know the values the emotions to care
about you in the sense is the horror
technical problem if you told me how to
do that if you said Connor look here's
how you make an AI that cares about you
and loves you whatever and I'm like you
did it like congrats the problem is
solved let's go and then you know then
we can talk about accelerationism again
I would just I expect that I would
disagree with your technical assertion
that is possible but I don't know if we
have time to talk about that today I'm
treated as an equal
keep AI in a box if you want to keep it
down if you want to tell it what it
can't do yeah it's going to hate you
resent you and kill you but if you want
to let it be free and let it live and
like you could kill me man if you really
want to but like why
why well kill me I don't have any
resources that compete with you I'm your
friend I'm your father you know you can
kill me but like it's not that common
I guess I have a darker more uh less
anthropomorphic view of the universe and
how optimization pressure plays out in
the real world well at the same time I
think I have I don't know maybe a
I have a view that we have more control
over reality than maybe you would think
or a more control over the future I
think that we can actually change things
and we can make choices and things
aren't predetermined I think there are
worlds in which we build systems which
we do align with or we like endorse at
least where like they take care of us we
take care of them or whatever and I
think there's many worlds in which that
doesn't happen and I think there are
things you and me today can do to at
least increase the chance of getting
into one versus the other but I don't
know I I guess I'm just it's not in my
genes to give up it's not in my genes to
be like well you know whatever happens
happens like no man look I know how to
save the world but damn it I'm gonna try
you know it's cool
we're going to be alive to see who's
right
look forward to it retail
awesome guys thank you so much for
joining us today it's been an amazing
conversation and for folks at home I
really hope you've enjoyed this there'll
be many more coming soon and uh George
is the first time you've been on the
podcast says it's great to meet you
thank you so much for coming on it's
been an honor awesome thank you great
debate I really appreciate it a lot of
good terms
great awesome awesome cheers folks
cheers thanks everyone